death eaters are wreaking havoc in both
the wizarding world and the muggle world
snape makes the unbreakable vow to
protect malfoy and has finally made the
defense against the dark arts teacher
harry finds the book of the half-blood
prince which is basically a cheat code
crush it don't cut it and wins him some
liquid luck a super powerful potion that
makes you well lucky meanwhile this is
the year of relationship drama ron gets
with lavender which makes hermione
jealous and harry and jenny finally snog
the field loves keem sting students and
professors alike keep unknowingly trying
to kill dumbledore via cursed necklace
and poison drink harry uses the liquid
luck to learn about voldemort's
horcruxes from professor slughorn
leading dumbledore and harry to find a
fake horcrux draco and the death eaters
arrived to kill dumbledore it's been
draco trying to kill him the whole time
which is really messed up he's gonna
kill me not to worry though snape
arrives and everything is going to be
a-okay
remember when these were kids movies
students and staff gather around the
scene of the crime and it swans up for
dumbledore this is extremely tragic and
traumatizing for everyone but at least
things can't get any worse for these
characters isn't that right dobby